[Applause]
spe
good
morning dear
colleagues we have with us the
president of the government of Spain
Prime min Minister Pedro Sanchez with us
today can I please ask you to take your
seats dear prime minister welcome to the
European Parliament and thank you for
being with us in times of geopolitical
change we have a joint
responsibility to promote social justice
democracy and the rule of law citizens
look to us to defend European values
dear Pedro let me thank your country for
its supports to Ukraine and to Spain's
team for the achievements of the Spanish
presidency of the European
Council with the artificial intelligence
act together we have delivered the
world's F first set of legislation to
manage Ai and promote
Innovation with the critical R we will
secure EU supplies and European
sovereignty with a political deal on an
anti-s slab directive we will protect
journalists we are nearing the end of
the year but there is still a lot of
work to do as we've just had the
opportunity um uh to talk about our
Focus remains on trying to find a way
forward on remaining files particularly
on migration people expect us to deliver
and we must so prime minister the floor
is
yours
president metola president fion vice
president shf kovich High representative
burel honorable
members I'd like to start with a brief
reference to the
date normally it's at the beginning of a
president
prescy that the country of the
presidency comes to Parliament and talks
through the priorities but bringing
forward elections to the 23rd of July
2023 meant that this was not such uh uh
suitable approach so I'm
actually before you in the last few days
of the presidency not to talk through
what we're planning to do but to talk
about what we have done what we've
achieved and what remains to be
done I hope it's been worth the
wait and I think it might have been
because in the meantime we've gained a
significant Ally for the next four years
with a progressive government in Spain
Spain was faced with a choice with two
different visions of the European
construction the right and far
right
to row back on social and environmental
progress as achieved in Spain in recent
years applying the failed neoliberal
formula which did so much to worsen the
recent financial crisis the other option
was a progressive Coalition where
despite having certain differences we
wanted to make progress we wanted to
continue consolidating the European
project we wanted to go for social
justice for uh labor reform for respect
and uh
Democratic uh cohabitation the right
cause is feminism green uh transition
strengthening our common project which
is the European project those
Progressive forces won the elections
fortunately and formed a new
Progressive coalition government on the
16th of November with 179 seats in the
uh Parliament and Absol abolute majority
the will of the people
expressed when uh over 12 million people
but isbit with uh groups which are not
part of the government providing uh
support and we will always support the
EU European values and principles and
the leadership which we have shown in
the rotating presidency of council I
think Bears witness to that and here we
have the second reason why I hope it has
been worth uh the wait it has been a
successful presidency I hope I would say
that we've had 43 files approved for
instance more than average we've
achieved significant progress in terms
of legislation and policies for the
future of
Europe obviously uh time means I can't
mention all of them but I would like to
mention a few We Set four priorities at
the beginning of the presidency when we
presented our
objectives firstly giving a push to
reindustrialization and achieving open
strategic autonomy in the EU our
citizens have faced a lot of
difficulties over the last few years
there's been a shortage of uh Sanitary
products
masks countries that were worst hit by
the effects of the pandemic early on
climate change economic social and
environmental consequences of that
Putin's war in Ukraine had an impact on
Energy prices and there's an economic
impact on citizens Pockets we need to
learn from that and improve the
international
order has been discussed in this chamber
of course the international order is
changing and Europe needs to change to
massive industrial Outsourcing to other
continents Blind Faith in import has to
go we need more domestic produ
production we need to be competitive in
sectors where we're at the Vanguard and
we need to be going for the industries
of the future so that we have more
companies and more quality jobs for our
citizens for that we need more uh
Innovation industrial policy and we need
to further develop the single
Market this doesn't mean that we should
be anti-globalization that we should be
protectionist some say that on the far
right for instance what I'm talking
about is strengthening domestic industry
becoming more efficient this is vital
this is what we need for the future of
the European economy but we'll always be
more prosperous if we cooperate with
other countries a few figures that I
think are quite eloquent quite eloquent
here if we look at our participation in
the global economy 40% of GDP in Europe
depends on that and one in five jobs in
the EU depends on that so rather than
closing ourselves off in an isolationist
way we need more trade expansion
consolidating diversifying and enlarging
our links with the outside world
modernizing multilateral architecture
development Aid commitment to the
welfare of other countries particularly
those in the global South this is the
vision for the future which the Spanish
presidency has endeavored to build over
the 6 months of presidency this is a
vision which the 27 heads of state and
government endorsed at the recent
informal Council in the Spanish city of
Granada and we very much hope that this
new strategic agenda for Europe will be
taken forward in the next uh presidency
over the course of the presidency I
think the EU has taken many steps
forward the president of the European
Parliament has referred to this too
we've had Pioneer
legislation on supply of critical raw
materials green and digital technology a
pioneering piece of legislation for
developing and adopting AI in Europe
while respecting our interests and the
interests of our citizens we've also
taken IND decisions to defend the
modernization of Agriculture and here
too the parliament the European
Parliament deserves congratulation for
the agreement which we've achieved and
also yesterday's agreement on Fisheries
that will ensure uh the future
prosperity of thousands of Spanish and
European families we also have New
Economic Security Instruments protecting
us against cotion from third countries
and protecting free movement of goods
services and people times of Crisis
within our single Market at the same
time what we were doing all that we've
also taken the external agenda forward
EU CAC I think that was a historic
meeting with Latin America and the
Caribbean and that trade agreement with
mercosur with new trade agreements with
Chile New Zealand with the organization
of African Latin American and Pacific
States is highly significant this will
mean something to the citizens of Europe
this will mean that we have more trade
with those countries and this will help
us to diversify our supply chains
the second priority along with
reindustrialization and open strategic
autonomy was to make progress with the
green transition and the adoption of
measures that would allow us to uh deal
with the effects of the climate
emergency as
Europeans we need to stop climate change
and environmental degradation it's not
only about survival it's also a huge
opportunity if we do it right if we are
resilient and persistent over the next
few years if we don't use crises to
postpone our action on the climate
emergency then our action will make us
more prosperous and more competitive
we'll be creating new Industries we'll
be increasing one point of GDP year on
year every year and over a million new
jobs only within this decade this will
also help us to drastically reduce our
energy dependency raw materials coming
from outside the EU just think of how
vulnerable Europe is to Putin's Russia
Bringing Down the electricity bill that
our citizens have to pay making our
companies more competitive and something
that people don't mention often enough
and I would like to to raise it here
reducing disease will be saving uh over
300,000 lives per year which are
currently lost due to uh air pollution
and adverse climate events so what I'm
saying with all of this is that the
green agenda is not what the far right
would have it's not an obstacle to
Europe's competitiveness actually it is
the great hope for Europe so I hope that
Europe has taken significant steps
forward in the Spanish presidency we've
achieved agreements to
reduce polluting gases from industry to
make Aviation more sustainable we've
approved pioneering regulations that
will allow us to reuse waste better and
have more sustainable repairable
recyclable
products and here too I would like to
thank the European Parliament for its
work we've achieved something which is
very important to this presidency which
is the nature restoration bill this will
allow us to recover ecosystems which
have been subject to degradation in
Europe we have presented a common front
together with the president of the
European Commission in cop
28 and we've heard
that at least will be uh
transitioning it is my
conviction that in the not too distant
future the regions with the most growth
will be the regions growing in harmony
with nature thanks to the measures that
we are currently adopting I believe
Europe can be at the Forefront of that
economy which is balanced with nature
reindustrialization adaptation
responding to the climate emergency also
social justice and economic
Justice in the second half of the 20th
century as a consequence of the Franco
dictatorship in the utari that we
suffered for four decades in Spain two
million Spaniards including my
grandfather and father immigrated to
Europe looking for jobs looking for
opportunities sadly they didn't have
those jobs and opportunities within
Spain they had to face some prejudice
they had to face some
rejection but they also got a welcome
they got a welcome from tolerant people
people who were open up the doors of
their
houses they got married to some of these
people they formed truly European
families and it was here in Europe that
our parents and grandparents discovered
something wonderful which is that jobs
are not just putting about putting food
on the table it's about dignity in life
and they also discovered that a welfare
state system can ensure public health
education decent pension for people who
retire and when they went back to Spain
once the dictatorship was over those
migrants brought back with them that
progress and they brought back with them
some
aspiration they voted they took part in
trades unions they were active in
business they worked for the Spanish
economy to be something more than
prosperous for it to be fair as well and
we govern in Spain with those values we
want that reality to continue and the
reason I say that is that Europe needs
more competitiveness yes we need to
increase our productivity to continue
growing we also need to ensure that
opportunities and wealth which is
generated gets through to everyone to
all Transitions and that the cost of the
green and digital transitions are not
creating a bill which is footed by the
most vulnerable in society and I think
we've achieved significant progress in
this presidency we have reached a
majority of member states and social uh
Representatives at the tripartite social
uh
Summit with the council rotating
presidency commission and Parliament in
October in Brussels and I believe that
we're on the verge of achieving
something very important which is a
historic uh reform of the electricity
Market this will allow not only a boost
to Renewables but it will bring down
electricity bills it will make them more
stable it will make the system more
transparent which means more information
to Consumers to fellow citizens and it
will protect citizens against abuse by
energy
multinationals we've also approved
various measures that will strengthen
consumer rights that will also improve
the labor rights of millions of workers
we've also achieve significant progress
in in other areas not just in the social
pillar but the
disability card new measures to combat
structural violence in all European
societies violence against women as a
form of structural violence trafficking
in human beings increasing the rights of
other vulnerable
communities now we just have the midterm
review of the mff uh to deal with and of
course that will be on the uh agenda
this week and indeed tomorrow and the
reform of fiscal rules we very much hope
that there will be an agreement before
the end of the year on that which will
allow us to keep uh to to balance the
books for Public Accounts and also meet
member states obligations to security
and uh defense digital and green
transitions social benefits and
everything else which citizens right F
expect so I very much hope that that
will be achieved by the end of the month
our fourth priority was strengthening
European Unity over the last few years
as you all know very well Europe has
been suffering tensions and attacks
there were those who wished to divide us
but they failed they didn't succeed
actually we are more cohesive and
stronger than ever nobody's celebrating
brexit nobody wants to leave the EU
anymore except for a few people on on
the very far right nobody's talking
about leaving the EU anymore nobody's
saying we should have uh looser links
between member States citizens now
support the European project more than
ever partly because of our response to
the pandemic and this is true across the
territory of Europe I think we've
learned a very important lesson
honorable members it's a World of Giants
and in order to prosper you need to come
together you need to integrate
internally you need to coordinate when
you're faced with external all
challenges and for that reason as the
president of the European Parliament
said earlier we need to celebrate the
achievements the Asylum and migration
pact for instance and I undertake to
work on a pact which is good for Europe
and for all of our societies over the
next few weeks this will allow us to
better
manage migration irregular migration and
to strengthen the external dimension of
cooperation with Transit countries and
countries of origin and logically too of
course we will be calling for an orderly
uh migration
policy with coordination across member
states parliamentary agreement on treaty
reform significant achievements on
enlargement with a significant landmark
in Granada that will hopefully be
validated at the European Council
tomorrow the time has now come for the
EU to open its doors and wel
in Ukraine and
Moldova and the Western Balan
countries we should also consolidate our
European political uh
community over 40 heads of state and
government came to Granada we've seen
unanimous uh cohesive support for
Ukraine in its striving for freedom and
EU
membership I just want to tell you a
quick story I started the Spanish
presidency with a trip here in July and
I hope to end the presidency with the
launching of the accession
[Applause]
talks but what we all hope for and I
include myself here is that we'll come
back here very soon to celebrate the
withdrawal of Russian troops and a
longlasting fair peace in that country
which is fighting so hard for its own
freedom and for
[Applause]
ours
Clarity and
unity that's what characterizes Russ our
response to Russia's unjustified
aggression and that has stopped crime it
has saved
lives when Europe is clear and United it
can do that so looking at what happened
yesterday at the general assembly of the
UN in New York we need to speak with the
same Clarity and unity about what is
happening in Israel and
Palestine if we want the world to
respect us as an actor on the
geopolitical
stage as a credible relevant body if we
want the people of Europe to be proud of
us and see that European values are not
just words we need to speak out loud and
clear with one voice we need to condemn
terrorist atrocities committed by Hamas
we need to call for unconditional
immediate release of all hostages taken
by Hamas we need to support combating
terrorism in the Middle East and we need
to recognize Israel's right to defend
itself and to exist without any doubt
whatsoever but with the same conviction
and the same values we need to say
enough enough death of innocent
civilians in Gaza including thousands of
children
bombing must stop immediately we need a
humanitarian ceasefire humanitarian Aid
is urgently needed in sufficient quanti
quantity for people who are suffering
from Hunger thirst and cold
International humanitarian law needs to
be respected and we need to play an
active role in contributing to a
definitive integral solution to this
conflict to give a prospect for credible
serious peace to give form to the
two-state solution the European
Parliament has recognized that the state
of Palestine needs to live in peace and
security alongside the state of
[Applause]
Israel for this as for Ukraine Europe
needs unity and over the next few months
Spain will do whatever it can can to
forge that Unity unity in diversity and
unity in
adversity I think those need to be our
slogans in the EU in these very complex
times
president honorable
members I'd like to conclude with some
thoughts about the future and ourselves
here in this chamber there are political
forces who do not believe in the
EU they think Europe is a decadent
spoiled Society
TR that we're trying to achieve green
transition
and social equality or welfare that we
cannot afford such people will repudiate
the achievement of achievements of the
last few decades they're afraid of the
future they hark back to a glorious past
which actually never existed and is
therefore impossible to go back to I
don't share that pessimism I do not
share that reactionary
mindset yes of course there are things
that can be improved the things which
aren't working but this should never
make us forget that despite it all
Europe makes progress Europe is
progressing it has never stopped since
the second world war and there is no
empirical evidence to indicate that we
will cease to do this in future Europe
has all the necessary ingredients to
continue being what it is today one of
the most prosperous socially Advanced
regions on the planet honorable members
we constitute half of uh Global
investment in
well-being we are world leaders in trade
we receive foreign direct investment
we're number two in terms of innovation
EOS uh ecosystem we have the talent we
have the business we have the public
institutions which are necessary to be
at the Forefront of the green transition
and to develop the industry of the
future and that's not an opinion that
is born out by the facts there's
evidence now we should not be complacent
we cannot rest on our Laurels we need to
be active there are a lot of problems
that need to be solved and there are a
lot of injustices that need to be
corrected but I say this because we do
need to constantly bear in mind our huge
potential it is possible to build a
Europe with clean cheap energy with full
employment with decent wages with decent
public services and with a better
standard of living
for social Improvement of uh all
citizens the time has come to look to
the future with more ambition and with
more optimism because the EU is facing a
challenge now which is not about
avoiding
decline it's not about the development
of other regions around the world we
need to be at the Forefront of a new era
of uh Global Prosperity honorable
members it is my firm conviction that we
can achieve that I'll leave at that
thank you very much prime minister
Sanchez I
[Applause]
now I now give the floor to the
president of the commission on L to take
the
floor pleas president of the
commission thank you very
much thank you very much Madame
President De Roberta prime minister dear
Pedro honorable
members when I look back at the Spanish
presidency the first images that come to
my mind are the breathtaking venues
where Spain hosted the
Summits the Royal collections in Madrid
phenomenal the alhamra in Granada
unique but besides the beauty of Spain
this presidency will be remembered for
incredibly challenging
circumstances I will never forget it was
the day after our meeting in
Granada where we discussed actually the
Russian war in
Ukraine we woke up to the news of Hamas
terrorist attack on the 7th of
October and these two conflicts have
shaped our work in these months but in
spite of these crisis we have still
managed to focus on a huge set of
priorities ranging from competitiveness
to climate and energy from economic
governance to migration and artificial
intelligence actually successfully just
concluded and allow me to focus on three
crucial issues that have marked these
six months first the situation in the
Middle East Second our work on energy
and third on
migration on
isra two months ago I was in Israel in
the quaza kibuts just after the Hamas
terrorist attacks and last month I was
in Rafa where we are working hand inand
with Egypt and the United Nations to
bring more assistance to
Gaza
Israel has the right to do everything in
its power to stop the horrors of 7th of
October being
repeated at the same time Israel has the
duty to do everything in its power to
protect civilians even if they are being
used as human Shields by
Hamas Hamas could stop fighting free the
hostages and stop hiding behind
civilians the paes in
hostilities enabled us to uh increase
Aid to Gaza with the help of numerous o
NGS the EU has organized 24 humanitarian
flights with more than 1,000 tons of
humanitarian Aid and six more flights
will be operated by the end of the year
on top of emergency
assistance we have to get the two-state
solution back on track there can be no
peace without a political future for the
Israelis and for the Palestinians and
there are three areas of
work on which we should concentrate
firstly the principles for the day
after and following the debate in the
European Parliament a month
ago the consensus on uh these principles
is now strengthened our diplomatic
action must continue also with a view to
holding an International Peace
conference then there is the situation
on the West
Bank Violence by extremist
settlers is endangering the prospects of
a large Las in peace and it could
increase Regional
instability that is why I am in
favor of uh penalties for those
responsible for the attacks in the West
Bank they must be brought to Justice
they have nothing to do with the those
attacks have nothing to do with the
fight against Hamas and must
stop and that brings me
to my uh third point which is to avoid a
regional
conflagration we have
seen uh on Israel's northern border
exchanges of fire with hisbah there have
been ballistic missile and drone attacks
on Israel and attacks on ships in the
Red Sea all of this is
dangerous and escalation can be avoided
we have to work with all the
international actors to stop the spread
of violence and to open up prospects for
peace we have to do what we can to end
this war and uh renew hope
gold ladies and gentlemen let me now
bring bring me
to another subject of uh my
presidency
energy I haven't forgotten what it was
like at the beginning of Russia's war in
Ukraine when 50% of our piped gas came
from Russia we were dependent and Russia
systematically tried
to uh blackmail us gas prom didn't fill
the uh storage t
s we had to deal with the energy crisis
but we
managed we were able to end our
dependence on Russian fossil fuels less
than 10% comes from there
now we're always strong when we join
forces we now have a joint purchasing
platform and remember what the situation
was was a year ago here in Europe now we
have
42 billion cubic MERS of gas procured
jointly for Europe and prices are 10
times
lower
uh we have stocks at levels around
93% that means that the time of Russian
blackmail using oil and gas is behind
[Applause]
us and we have made huge investments
into
Renewables we produce more uh
electricity in Europe from uh sun and
wind than from gas we're modernizing our
rules and we are on the cusp of an
electricity Market to
reform finally uh people will be able to
benefit from renewable energy at
affordable
prices the cop 28 in Dubai has just
reached a historical deal and a crucial
part of it is truly made in Europe we
can be proud of that because we proposed
the global pledge to Triple renewable
energy and to double energy efficiency
by
2030 130 countries immediately joined us
and now the whole world has endorsed our
Targets in the Final Cup declaration
this is really thank you thank something
to be very proud of it I think this is a
global turning point for the first time
the world is committing to transition
away from fossil fuels for the first
time there is a loss and damage fund to
support the most vulnerable countries
IES so this has the potential to be the
beginning of a new era the post fossil
era let's celebrate this Europe is at
the Forefront of it investing in clean
and homegrown energy for all this is the
right direction of
travel honorable members my third point
is
migration in the last six months
pressure on our external borders has
continued to rise not only on the
Central and Eastern Europe uh
Mediterranean but also in the Atlantic
and most recently at finland's eastern
border a reckless hybrid attack
orchestrated by
Russia and this is yet another proof
that migration is a European Challen
Challenge and needs a European answer
and solution and this is the spirit that
has driven our action throughout this
mandate in the recent months
we have continued advancing on four main
strands of work first we have
strengthened our external borders
Bulgaria for example or Romania now we
are supporting Finland with an increased
presence of frontex to Patrol its
borders second we are combating
Smugglers we had almost 60 countries
taking part in our International
Conference to form a Global Alliance to
counter migrant smuggling because we
need to pull our way together to fight
Smugglers this is organized crime
actually internationally organized crime
so it needs an international organized
answer and to get me right yes we have
an obligation as part of the
International Community to support those
with the right to protection and to save
lives we have fulfilled it in the past
we fulfill it today today and we will
fulfill it in the future but we decide
who comes to the European Union and
under what circumstances and not the
Smugglers and
traffickers and it is for this reason
that we have proposed to update our
anti-smuggling legislation it was 20
years old so it is now up to you
Parliament and Council to bring this
forward as a matter of
urgency third on
returns we now have a road map focusing
on seven priority countries frontex is
supporting member states from
identification to join return joint
return
operations and these countries are ready
to cooperate with us our offer is
clear we can grant more opportunities to
come to Europe legally safe legal
Pathways and we expect cooperation to
ensure the return of irregular migrants
that this happens and this leads me to
my fourth point a comprehensive
partnership we need to strike a new
balance with countries beyond our
borders in those countries migration is
part of a much broader picture it
includes not only M management and
anti-smuggling but also investment in
the economy peop to- people exchanges
trade job creation youth employment all
the root causes we know very well and
therefore this approach is now beginning
to show results for example in Tunisia
The Irregular departure from SX have
slowed down and we now work to reach
similar agreements with Egypt soon where
migration is also part of a much much
broader pict picture and we want to
create a partnership on this border
picture and with other countries of
origin and Transit this is the external
side and then in the internal side we
have the new pact on migration and
Asylum it is about to get over the
finish line that is good and let me
thank the Spanish presidency and the
Parliament for working patiently and
working
relentlessly to build common round with
everyone's goodwi and flexibility
towards a common goal we can get this
pack done and over the finish line so
let us show to our citizens that Europe
can manage migration effectively and
humanely let us show once again the
power of Europe when it stands tall and
United thank you very much and Long Live
Europe
no
no dear colleagues we must have a
support animal in the
house dear colleagues can I now give the
floor to the representatives of the
political groups starting with the
president of the EP group group Manfred
Weber for four
minutes so it's obviously another
another supporter and fan ofine here in
the flener so Mr Sanchez welcome and
congratulation to your election as prime
minister of Spain you know politically
I'm not happy but as Democrats we
respect the outcome you are today
present to present the main outcome of
the Spanish presidency and rep you
reported to today quite technically but
you are not here as a an official you
are here as a prime minister and
politically I have to say the EU
presidency is not a success story and I
give you some arguments for this you
spoke about the economic future of
Europe measur 700 million consumers the
biggest single Market in the world we
expected that you make sure that we sign
it that South America doesn't fall into
the hand of China have you spoken with
macron about this Ukraine membership
support you spoke about this have you
also spoken with Orban about this if the
council fails in this historic moment
this week it's all Sanchez failure and
on the Hamas attacks to Israel you
overshadowed the last council meeting
you divided Europe when you were
applauded by Hamas terrorists probably
to please more the left sumar but not to
unite Europe Mr Sanchez you have spoken
and also I have spoken about democracy
and the basic principle of democracy is
to tell the people the truth before the
elections you cannot promise not to give
an amnesty until 3 days before the
elections and then you give it you
cannot be in power for 5 years saying
that an amnesty is not constitutional
and then you do it yesterday the Spanish
Parliament started the debate about the
amnesty law a law where your socialist
predecessor Philipe Gonzalez opposed
publicly and also said called it a risk
for the Spanish Constitution Europe is
worried the commission is asking serious
question Mr Sanchez today I only want to
priorize one special point
in the Coalition text you signed you
promised to put demon a special
Committee in the Spanish Parliament to
check judgments a special committee on
laware that goes fundamentally against
rule of law against the separation of
power and yesterday in the Spanish
Parliament when the team of put demon
were putting individual judges in the
speech even the Socialist team in the
parliament were silent and shocked about
what happened there so I have only one
question will you go with the Socialist
team in the parliament in favor of such
committee yes or no and I'm sure you
will not deliver today I'm sure and that
is then appr Pro that the investigation
from the European Parliament commission
is needed is urgently needed to have a
look what is happening in Spain Europe
is proud about U very strong socialists
will BR
framon and today
irach we see now the developments in
Spain where people are concerned we see
the problems in Portugal where prime
minister's Chief of Staff caught 7 ,000
in his office backs of cash Costa
immediately resigned we had this skylie
case now one year ago and just to
remember to recall ourself it is not a
parliament's scandal it is until now
only a socialists Scandal which is on
the table and we have also Slovakia
where we have a pro Putin team being
there still member of the Socialist
Party irach in Europe Pelini and also
fito so I think you have a lot to do uh
in your Camp to clarify the situation
there on the European level Mr Sanchez I
finally want to express one General
point we may have different uh opinions
on on on on on content socialists
Christian democrats but for this
European project it was always clear to
unite that Europe can only stand on two
Feats and not only on one that's why
socialists and Christian democrats must
find a common understanding that was the
same what Alberto together with other
screens and renew but uh that was
exactly was Alberto Foo was proposing in
Spain to bring the country together to
heal the bounds to exclude separatists
extremists from left and right from
getting power you refused this I want to
underline I want to underline that for
us as ep the next European commission
must be based on a cooperation on the
center parties in this European
Parliament and I hope that the European
socialists will not do the same as you
did to refuse the cooperation with the
center parties in Europe you will meet
tomorrow in Brussels my predecessor as
president of the European People's Party
you will meet Donald Tusk now elected
prime minister of Poland he defeated
kachinski and he will restore rule of
law in Poland that is EP that is Alberto
foo's party in Europe and we are proud
about this he will bring back rule of
law to PO Poland and we will also do the
same in Spain and Madame President as a
final Point let me recall the words of
Martin Luther King which should be an
inspiration for the upcoming Christmas
break I quote every man must decide
whether he will walk in the light of
creative altruism or in the darkness of
destructive selfishness dear Madame
President Madame Prim Madame commission
president ministers dear colleagues this
is a a quote which we can reflect on I
wish you all Merry Christmas and a Happy
New Year
I give the floor now to the president of
the snd group irache Garcia
Perez
gracias thank you thank you
president dear prime minister Sanchez
welcome to the European
Parliament
to the house of speech and understanding
thank you for your leadership in the
courageous historic and United resp
during the pandemic and Putin's war
against Ukraine to protect the middle
and working classes because despite
resistance from the right and the far
right you have managed to lead the way
in building a union with greater social
justice Mr Sanchez in the face of our
right and extreme right that' only
understand a Homeland as being a land of
hatred lies and disloyalty you have the
Social Democratic family at your side so
that you can continue to lead the great
Transformations that our Union needs
because our common Homeland the European
Homeland is built with a more social
Union that guarantees Fair wages minimum
income and paid internships and also a
housing policy policy at the service of
citizens especially the
youngest the European Homeland is being
built with more equality because the
21st century is a century of
women and no Triumph will be more
important than the eradication of gender
violence a macho violence that the
extreme right does not even recognize
the European Homeland is built with more
individual rights and more public
freedoms in a union where lgtbi people
can also feel think or love as they wish
in Union that respects immigrants under
the protection of a new pact on
migration and Asylum based on solidarity
between states the European Homeland is
built with a union at the Forefront of
the fight against climate change because
thanks to science we know that we have
to limit the rise in temperature and
that we have no alternative but to
comply with the green deal reform the
electricity Market to reduce prices and
accelerate the use of renewable energies
the European Homeland is also built with
an open strategic autonomy it is built
with a more Humane digital
transformation it is built with a
reformer fiscal rle rules to strengthen
public services and it is built by
turning the European Union into an
exporting power of Peace because if we
responded to Putin's war against Ukraine
with unity and
firmness and I believe we did we must
show the same unity and firmness to lead
an International Peace conference that
makes it possible for Israel and
Palestine to live in peace
how can the People's Party and vo wrap
themselves in the flag of patriotism
when they've tried to torpedo the
implementation of the 160 billion in the
recovery plan for Spain when they've
disqualified ruled out the Iberian
exception that led to a saving of 5
billion in the price of electricity and
when they've tried to boycott a pension
reform agreed with the commission that
improves the purchasing power of our
elderly Mr vber what is your project for
Europe I know what your project was to
make abas scal the deputy leader the
same in Spain the same man who takes
photos with meone Mone Oran and moravi
the same man who asks for people to
hang prime minister Sanchez by his feet
so with your autocratic partners and
when you're blocking
renewing the national judicial Council
for five years don't give me lessons
about the rule of law your alliance with
the farri has only one project anti-
Europe because nothing is more
anti-european than building walls
against the weakest nothing is more
anti-european than
discrimination and
endangering
coexistence by pitting compatriots
against compatriots Dear Mr Sanchez on
the 23rd of July you succeeded in
stemming the reactionary tide in Spain
your Victory brought hope to the
Democratic forces of Europe to continue
building a fairer Union so that the
generations of today and tomorrow
looking back will be able to say the EU
was up to the task thank you very much
so the president of U of the renew group
Stefan seun for three minutes
minut Merc
Madame thank you Madame
President prime minister
colleagues a council presidency at the
end of term is always a challenge the
expectations are huge and rightly so it
requires a cool head and a steady
hand my group I'm sorry to have to say
would have prefer referred if the
opening of the presidency had not been
unnecessarily polluted by national
issues this house often tends
to uh uh do this whenever uh Prime
Ministers are in on the premises
nonetheless you uh know my group's
attachment to the fundamentals of the
rule of law notably judicial
Independence and no national law should
try to duck those and my group will pay
close attention to the European
commission's
recommendations nevertheless uh the
Spanish presidency's resolve is
impressive and uh we wanted results for
our citizens and we can see these
results and our colleagues who were shut
away
for uh hours negotiating on artificial
intelligence can testify we're the first
continent to lay down The rules
electricity Market reform was necessary
given energy price
inflation and I think we have
uh uh made substantial progress there we
need an agreement acceptable to all we
already have an agreement on Raw for
materials which is vital for
our economy and you mentioned a number
of points you
also uh stayed the course on the green
transition with uh
agreements as part of the green deal on
nature
restoration uh the ban on emissions
dangerous to health and E product e
design nonetheless uh my group wants to
see uh more done
to conclude two important uh
negotiations the Asylum and migration
PCT and the stability and growth
pact we Europe's leaders in
2020 should not uh repeat what happened
happened in
2010 we really need a United and
efficient Europe on these matters these
are two files on which Europe's image
will depend and it will be your
presidency's legacy there's work
therefore to be done the this
parliamentary term is not over we uh
don't know yet the outcome
and on these two issues in particular
your presidency's legacy will depend of
the green group Terry RKA for 2
minutes thanks a lot uh dear colleagues
dear prime minister Dear Presidents more
than 620 billion euros are needed for
the green transition annually over
€15 billion EUR are needed for
digitalization in Europe each year
384 billion EUR are needed within the
next 10 years for the Reconstruction of
Ukraine Defense Education You Name It We
urgently need investment and especially
after the Breakthrough at the cop this
morning this is also about our Global
credibility because in action colleagues
will only make the future more expensive
and dear prime minister I'm not going to
lie we would have hoped and we still
hope for a more Progressive negotiation
on the reform of the stability and
growth PCT in the past six months
because we both know that if we are not
careful we are sleepwalking into the
next Crisis despite the fact that we
should know better by now Europe has no
time to lose Europe can under no
circumstances fall back into the fade
failed ideology of austerity during the
corona pandemic we have seen that our
critical infrastructure is far more than
tracks and Roads depth rules that are
tying us down disproportionately are a
barrier for prosperity for justice they
are a barrier for our common future and
especially as a German right now I can
tell you I know what I'm talking about
this is not for the greens and their
climate investment this is for our e
economic competitiveness of this
continent functioning infrastructure is
crucial to connect this continent even
closer to build a truly integrated
single Market the US is massively
investing China is moving the world is
not waiting for us colleagues just
Europe is lagging behind because we have
a number of ideological dinosaurs in our
midst who do not understand that smart
investment is needed right now
colleagues this is for our citizens this
is for future proof good jobs this is
for a strong industry this is for a
common European future so we count on
you in this debate and lastly and we all
know that this is probably going to be a
very noisy debate today but prime
minister you are very warmly welcome
here because we are happy that there is
a pro- European progressive government
in Spain that is going to fight with us
to shape the future instead of another
far-right party that wants to destroy
Europe thank you very much I give the
floor
next on behalf of the ECR group to bad
three
minutes thank you president Mr Sanchez
you will go in the history books
generations of Spaniards will be stying
your megalomaniacal narcissistic um
deceitful Behavior lacking in empathy
and your your control Frey millions of
Spaniards are living beneath a poverty
threshold
and suffering uh increased taxes
millions of Spaniards are unsafe on the
streets but you've left our borders open
to massive immigration feeding into to
the the business of human trafficking
mafias millions of Spaniards are
unemployed and you you you're putting
your your friends in positions of
responsibility to depriving Spain of
skilled officials serving the common
good all of knows you your water policy
and opening up farming to unfair
competition the
fight against uh population or and now
your your attempted could is exhausting
Spanish
patience we have to do away with
Privileges and oppose equality before
the you're going in the opposite
direction you have used a specific un
clearly unconstitutional law to Parton
those who' committed the most serious
offenses
against the Constitution this is a
backward step you're you're preventing
the constitutional judges for doing
their job they've all spoken out you're
attempted C you you're taking it back
centuries you're attempted
unconstitutional
action is leaving you with a debt that
you're going to have to
pay you your your party your census
propaganda lack any Authority and
legitimacy it's a result of deceiving
the the Spanish people a criminal
agreement signed in a a Brussels
hotel by fugitives from Justice
and a bunch of you serers but you
haven't got the guts to admit this
personally Mr Sanchez in February 1936
an anti-democratic uh popular front just
like yours given an amnesty to those
who'd risen up against the
Constitutional order of the Republic and
the unity of the country they also
alleged that what they wanted to do was
bring peace and calm to the
country and now the the spiritual area
of those
uh three C
comrades
as is is
continuing with the attitude that killed
M monies you're destroying everything
that our parents and grandparents worked
hard to achieve you will go down in the
history books as the Prime Minister
who's unable to walk along the streets
of Spain for fear of the Spanish people
and what's even
worse is that you're responsible for
what's happening to Spain what will
happen to Spain Spanish if if your law
goes through your but don't worry your
your threats aren't going to to make us
pip down we will move ahead Spanish
people will be there on the streets and
in the courts and we will be constantly
mobilized thank you very much I give the
floor now to Marco for one and a half
minutes
thanks
president
for
we are the goodies and you are the
baddies
because as we've seen in the past things
like migration economic governance
something which isn't working today
these are the keys to solve certain
problems which are causing real concern
to people thanks to your Splendid
Diplomat some important dosses have been
sorted out but a lot remain to be sorted
out you've got migration that's not
being done
yet and we can hope that the 10ts might
be sorted out on Monday there a
trialogue then I'm pleased to hear you
speak in the battle against terrorism a
former president of this house a few
weeks ago in Madrid was uh wounded in a
very serious attempt on his life
so as I say it's not a question of
goodies and baddies we've all done as
well as we can but you need to
understand that millions and millions of
Europeans sometimes in the so-called
extreme right as we calling us who
aren't happy with what's being done
thank you give the floor next to idoya V
Ru for the left group one and a half
minutes we are running very much behind
time
thank you very much uh Madam president
welcome president Sanchez to the
European Parliament and obviously we've
heard lots of accusations and we will
continue to hear lots of accusations
from the EP and this has become a
ridiculous custom in this house but
there are significant challenges and far
the far right is gaining ground in most
European
countries
but the Unos has
defended Brave measures which have been
the best antidote to the far
right there's been significant progress
in this half year the nature resolation
law artificial intelligence and also the
electric markets the um we've seen
movement on that as
well now one other um these are very
practical examples of what the European
Union can do for energy energy autonomy
we need to have public investment we
need to have renewable energy in the
hands of the
regions the European pillar and of
social rights and also equality are
important we need to have a social
pillar as a priority Spain has been
Pioneer in advancing women's rights and
this has been recognized
here but we also have seen a lack of
progress on the directive on
gender-based
violence there's a black hole abandoning
human rights and we are um working on a
pat of
migration and this is very
important but it's unacceptable
today to just have words and not have
specific action to deal with impunity
and to stop the genocide planned in
gazak Spain can and W
should
then also focus on those responsible and
not in European Project without
credibility we will never give in to the
uh far right thank you very much to Mr
Pim for one
minute
thank you president
fine prime minister SES in your speech
ofing the presidency you set out um
ambition you called for a Europe of
people meeting their their needs and
claims previous presidencies gave
similar statements and no doubt we'll
hear the same again in the future the
problem in Europe was never any lack of
promises the problem in in Europe is the
Fulfillment of these promises because
the failure to fulfill promises leads to
a lack of confidence that lack of
confidence may even undermine such a
solid project as the European Union a
union of people will be nothing if you
don't listen to people and put them at
the center of your decisions I'm talking
you today in in your mother tongue but
I'm unable to do so in my own mother
tongue millions of us in in Europe how
Catal as our mother tongue and we're not
able to exert such fundamental rights in
our language because
this is something you should be
defending your presidency we
we ah right to speak Catal here is is
not enforcing the way yours is now you
if if if out of if you act out out of
fear you never get positive
consequences thank you Madame President
Mr sanchezz speaking as a Spanish
Catalan to a Spaniard I'm going to put
my hand on my heart and tell you what
millions of Spaniards would like to tell
you face to face Spain says no to an
amnesty to a blow against democracy
ignoring hugely serious crimes of
terrorism and Corruption no to an
amnesty which you denied you do during
the election campaign and one that
creates two classes of Spaniards no to
an un intolerable amnesty in the words
of Felipe Gonzalez the social president
who brought Spain into the European
Union Spain says no to threatening
judges and creating laware committees
and we say no to the Supreme infamy of
transferring National sovereignty away
from Parliament to a shameful
clandestine Bureau not linked to the
European Union with an international
mediator between the Spanish government
and fugitives from Justice what a
wonderful presidency of the European
Union Mr Sanchez do you really think
that a few more months as PM are worth
destroying judicial Independence the
separation of powers and the equality of
spers before the law I'll give you none
out of 10 for patriotism 10 out of 10
for opportunism but you and
your partner the The Fugitive P deont
are wrong Spain isn't giving up no one's
laughing at Spain we're a great Nation
one of the great European Democracies
and that's why we will stay out on the
streets in the courts and in Europe
tirelessly saying no to your
amnesty colleagues the Sanchez amnesty
is selling Spain's dignity for seven
votes in order to stay in power your
report was false Mr Sanchez there's no
generosity here there's no greatness
there no kind of agreement all there is
is the personal interest of an
unprincipled politician whose word can't
be Trust willing to destroy everything
just to stay in office impunity in
exchange for power that's your legacy Mr
Sanchez and Europe needs to listen to
The Cry of Spain the Sanchez amnesty is
a disaster of Spanish democracy and
European values thank you thank you I
give the floor next to vice president
barley for one
minute thank you
president
welcome to the European Parliament
ped thank you very much dear prime
minister for a presidency that uh began
under a challenging circumstances but
that has achieved so many results um let
me just name two one is that we have
really come a long way on discussing new
rules on migration we're not there yet
but we're progressing and the other is
the I AI act that we managed um to
conclude with which the European Union
is the first area to regulate this
important topic and also congratulations
on how you managed to get Spain through
these difficult times excellent economic
data very low uh unemployment rates that
is really something now I only have a
minute of speaking time so I can't
really reply very much to all that has
been said about the
amnesty but as far as I can
see in these very difficult times when
you have a divided society and that has
happened more than once in Spanish
history amnesty has been a matter to
solve this and
if you manage that the Catalan separ
separatist parties renounce to pursue
their goal
unilaterally I think this is a great
achievement also for the rule of law
thank you I give the floor next to
Adrien Vasquez lazara one
[Applause]
minute thank you very much Miss V Vice
President Bell as well well been waiting
you waiting for you for six months in
this Parliament and what you've done is
what you always do you have explained
priorities that are not true because you
can't explain the real priorities it
would if only you'd been here six months
ago to talk about priorities for the EU
unblocking the migration path and then
trade agreements such as
mercosur and also fiscal rules as well
but
no what you decided to do was call some
snpp elections in which you went against
everything you
pledged and what you managed to do was
divide Spaniards you put ministers in uh
in in place and you talked to about
co-official uh languages as well to
increase and what you did is weaken the
political capital of this presidency and
then there's the amnesty law which
completely reverses the principle of
equality among Spaniards and you've also
given immunity to fugitives fugitives
who are looking at us here from up from
up there and this says to and this is
these messages to judges and the and
police from the Congress
and without this is not going to do well
thank you now to one
[Applause]
minute thank you president prime
minister we're in Strasburg so we're
going to talk about Europe from what
you've said today in your speech I agree
with your pro- European approach there
is the need to
defend European Unity particularly at a
time when we have the far right
Unchained with the shameful complicity
of the mainstream right I don't know if
I can share the optimism at the end of
your speech though you and I are
approximately of the same generation but
you do you
know between us and our parents they
were able to v i wonder whether we
can can now we have levels of poverty
inequality
precariousness and huge social pressure
in our societies there there's one
thing that you not much to do is Achieve
the official status of the Catalan
language as a question of language
Justice the speaker is continuing in one
of languages which not yet
official thank
you I give the floor to Carlo Fida for
one
[Applause]
minute thanks Madame President
Commissioners president Sanchez the
story of these six months of the Spanish
presidency will has been linked right
from the beginning with your own
government's
fate you
have played it a bold way with early
elections and then more seriously with
the rule of law the Spanish Constitution
and the laws and also the in European
institutions you in order to stay in
office have even tried to get Catalan
and Basque recognized as EU official
languages risking that another dangerous
president will be
created there have been ambitious
reforms of the stability and go growth
pack to try to get beyond the problems
of the past you've also nominated
somebody for the EI presidency that and
the green deal has actually been
worsened as we've seen on in the
packaging directive so there's much more
Shadow than light in these six months
and millions of Spaniards are more and
more worried about the future of their
great nation thank you president you
very much I give the floor now to Gar
Beck for one
minute if he's not here we go to Manu
Mano Bena I don't to Mr
Beck go ahead Manu
but he's not here so he'll come later
maybe go
ahead thank you Madame President prime
minister Sanchez
recently you described the genocide in
Gaza as an
indiscriminate mass and you were
abused by the Israeli government for
saying
this just as with the UN Secretary
General when you called for the
upholding of international
law the Israeli government feels it is
Justified to uh despise and insult well
I don't want to use crude words but take
this approach to anyone who calls for
international law to be upheld here it's
not just a a question of the children
dying in Gaza international law is also
dying if we do nothing to thought this
we may as well just give up on on the
whole structure of international set up
since the second world war which was
supposed to allow us to to solve Count's
problems peacefully let's be consistent
prime minister Sanchez we cannot call on
international law and talk about a
massacre if we don't do nothing about
this genocide history will condemn usas
deut is next one
minute
prime
minister well in your speech
today you talked about the activities
and the B biggest success stories of
your presidency and you said that one of
the biggest successes was staying in
power
and this
approach completely show shows a
complete misunderstanding of what the
presidency is for you shouldn't be
talking about staying in power and
electoral success as part of a
presidency colleagues we need to help
Ukraine and we can help
Ukraine however it's
becoming clearer and clearer that
Ukraine and the EU are not ready for
starting negotiations on
accession but Brussels bureaucracy is
doing all it can to not listen or not
pay attention to what's in people's
interests and there is uh significant
political pressure and they are trying
to force the accession of
Ukraine EU is not ready for the
accession of Ukraine and there there is
significant pressure from Ukraine and uh
Europe is falling for this thank
you graas Pres
thank you madam president president
Sanchez in December 2020 kashin Mr
kashinsky said that courts in Poland are
politically dependent on the opposition
you president Sanchez said about a week
ago that we're using public institutions
to attack political opponents in court
what's the difference please are you
aware does any is anyone aware about
an rule of law where parliamentary
committees can involve themselves in
ongoing legal
cases the there's a kind of big brother
being set up in stain the big judge who
is actually now overseeing all the real
courts that's what's happening political
manipulation of the legal system in
exchange for seven votes a similar thing
began years ago in the Salem witch
trials and if you want to convince us
then return the courts to the way they
ought to
be
because I don't believe in witches but
they do
exist one minute go ahead miss
pson one minute for Helen pson
yes go
ahead Premier Minister
Sanchez prime minister
Sanchez and
we are seeing um fights against
cohesion in Sweden as a good example of
this we have a conservative prime
minister
and the government is completely
dependent on the Swedish Democrats and
nationalistic party and this is in a a
time when we need more cohesion more
Unity we don't want to have a divided
Europe because a divided Europe will not
help resolve the cost of living
crisis or the fight against organized
crime we need to be strong
and for this reason we need unity in
Europe so thank you very much Mr Sanchez
for all your work focusing on equality
thank you very much
is one
[Applause]
minute
sanche welcome prime minister Sanchez
your presidency has achieved some
positive agreements for Europe some
linked to the fact that we signed up to
to support in University we need to
ensure the timely completion of trans
European networks which will
eliminate um bottlenecks which are
something vital for the Atlantic seab
board we agree to you about the uh the
system governing uh relations between
the the basad navares regional
governments and and their police forces
being fitted into the European
institutional
system we need the regional
program to get the Next Generation funds
through to uh to Industry and promote an
Atlantic macro region we will be um
demanding the the presence of the bask
language of the union we support
dialogue and and negotiation as a
European solution to Territorial and
national identity conflicts the when you
respect diversity it unites us treat
treating the special of views as as a
crime leads to confrontation the amnesty
you've proposed will restore the
situation in in in catalon and
strengthen the rule of
law thank you very much Mr Sanchez you
recognize a large number of galicians
who want another kind of Europe a Europe
of peoples because there are lots of
policies which affect our lives European
funds on work and energy transport the
economy because there's another kind of
Europe that's possible for peoples such
as
ours so we Mr
President want to stand up against the
Fascism and in favor
of coexistence we want to fight against
the corrupt and the Neo fascist speeches
which are holding Europe back we're
getting this from the extreme right and
the right in this who cool still call
themselves
Democrats
but there's been ex misuse of European
funds by the EP government in the pp
government in Galia your colleague to
now to Margarita de laiza Caron one
minute
thank you very much
colleagues I regret that
the Spanish presidency has not honored
the greatness of my
country perhaps what we've seen shows
that when the Dignity of humans is not
respected there are no limits to its
manipulation that's clear to us
women we are less safe your government
has reduced sentences and has freed sex
offenders and it does not stop those
that denigrate us and justify rape and
based on that logic it's not surprising
that you have no quals coming to
agreements with terrorists and remaining
silent in the face of atrocities and
under your
mandate criminals have been legitimized
and victims have been
neglected yesterday in the Spanish
Congress uh an amnesty law was presented
which perverts the Constitutional order
and puts our Unity at risk it will leave
us behind it will leave us with higher
unemployment debt and uh poverty the
opposite of what you have uh promised
your blah blah blah has stopped uh
Charming us span Spain is woken up and
Europe will follow us thank you um vsky
one and a half
minutes thank you thank you very much
Madame President ladies and uh gentlemen
on when it comes to the Spanish
presidency there's not much to say it's
really more of the
same and it's a bit like Groundhog Day
like the
film
because we haven't managed here to
reform the institutions or at least have
discussions about that to bring EUR the
European Union back to the
people
and we haven't managed to focus on the
conflict in Ukraine between Russia and
Ukraine we haven't managed to bring
people to round on on one table and to
ensure security for Europe none of that
has
happened in the next year
I am looking forward to positive
developments in the European elections
and hopefully there'll be a big majority
for the center right and that will move
the European Union towards a better
future in the second half of the year
when Hungary takes over the presidency
which many of you don't want to happen
but hopefully this
will allow our Hungarian friends
to move the EU in the right direction
away from
centralism focusing on the um war in
Ukraine this is what we need to do for
the future but thank you very much
Madame President and I would just like
to say that if when people from the left
speak they uh are able to speak for
their they extend their speaking time
but that all should also apply to people
from my group thank you to Rodriguez
phop one minute next
please
pres thank you president welcome prime
minister
santh the expectations of this
presidency were huge and it's been seen
as an opportunity for social progress
despite the fact that the right many
Spanish members of this house have tried
to boycott it today we're taking stock
of the situation Europe is greener more
social and more feminist than it was
there's been a start to the social
dialogue democracy at work health and
safety at
work care
um nature protection the green
transition of course we go much
further didn't get the um the ILO um
measure through but stressing strategic
autonomy has made you excessively
dependent on questionable trade deals
such as Mar Sword and the migration pact
May underline the right to Asylum
there's an agreement on the reform of
the Electric market to promote
Renewables but there are serious risks
of of lithium Mining and or solar panels
destroying fertile agricultural land to
replace
carbon in rightwing Europe they're
they're fighting social policy making a
noise improves no one's
life
fors president during the Spanish
presidency the EU was a disaster
citizens
again the sanctions against Russia led
to a further regression of living
standards the flight of Industry from
Germany and an economic
recession the increasing migration led
to Greater housing shortages increasing
um State debt and led to violence in our
cities countries such as
Hungary do stand up for their citizens
hry and svenia
prevented um
think this could be in
Poland has has also stood up and the and
Hungary has been opposing the accession
of Ukraine which would cost European
citizens
billions you trying to pay us being UNR
well I would tell the council to to stop
this country's to work on the European
Union let let's follow the example of of
the bricks for for
progress thank you Mr Sanchez let us be
honest the council presidency is the
best opportunity any country has to
influence the European agenda and to
promote itself unfortunately Mr Sanchez
you lost this opportunity for Spain what
did you do you lost the regional
election in May you called for an early
parliamentary election at the beginning
of the council presidency and lost it
and then you spent the whole Council
presidency negotiating an amnesty law
with persons who acted against the
Spanish Constitution while Spanish
diplomats made efforts here we had the
impression that you were more
preoccupied by granting amnesty to
separatists than by the success of the
presidency let me be clear the amnesty
law concerns the European Union a a
government granting amnesty to people
who broke the Constitution attack the
rule of law the amnesty law is an attack
upon the rule of law and we care about
the rule of law because the rule of law
is the European value and let me be
clear who wants to access European funds
needs to respect European values the
amnesty law and the attack upon the rule
of law risks blocking European funds to
Spain we saw that happening for Hungary
we saw that happening for for Poland it
can happen for Spain as well we do not
want that to happen we want to help the
people of Spain but we ask you prime
minister Sanchez not to be an obstacle
in the desire of the European Union to
help the people of Spain thank you very
much thank you we give the floor next
next to for one
[Applause]
minute thank you Madame
President will there be a or a time will
come when they're going to want to hang
Sanchez up by his feet as the someone in
the center right said in Spain hatte
speech so I'd like to express my
solidarity with President Sanchez who's
here today and all the anti-fascist
Democrats in Spain but despite that
Georgia balone asked Mr bascal the man
who said those things to
a meeting carried out by her party a
shameful thing against the history of
Italy which lived through an extreme
right dictatorship just like Spain did
we want a more powerful Europe on the
world stage we want Europe that grows
want Europe to be a force of peace and
international law when it comes to all
those conflicts going on around us the
Spanish presidency coming to an end has
achieved important results in these
areas and I need to mention the AI
regulation which I'm for which I'm co-
rapporter a brilliant result for our
citizens workers and companies please
keep up the good work siras one
minute thank you very much Madame
President and um prime minister I wanted
to in preparing this debate I decided to
look at the uh text uh about the um
president about the
presidency
and the you look at the Dorian Gale from
Oscar
wild this reflected the sins of the
protagonist and what are the sins in the
picture of
you the
responsibility for the snap elections at
the beginning of the
presidency and then also so negotiating
with criminals for the sake of seven
votes so that you could be
inaugurated
and you and but we know what the biggest
sin was that was sacrificing the most
sacred values of this chamber and the EU
rule of law and uh
equality
and your presidency will go down in
history because of your selfishness and
for sacrific ing European values for
seven votes
congratulations one minut
[Applause]
please thank you president prime
minister sanche there's a a global re
reactionary Network we we saw a clear
example of this a few days ago with with
Vox leaders um to sharing Kier
M's victory
this there should be a a global
Progressive uh coalition to to to fight
them but that will require courage and
Leadership and I'm sorry to have to say
that we haven't always seen much of that
during your presidency of the of the
council for example there's every
indication that your presidency will not
be able
to complete work on the directive
against gender based violence
and then on the amesty law well they you
you forced that because it seemed the
conflict between CIA and Europe is is
being turned into something European and
therefore requires a European solution
more of a a p more of a solution well
now we we can speak on Level Playing
Field and talk about Solutions we're we
are proposing a referendum what are you
going to propose prime minister
Sanchez Mr
Madame President
colleagues the only
thing one can say when summing up the
Spanish president it's already been said
and I'm sorry for repeating the words
that were
used it's selfishness
but this selfishness is some perhaps
shared by many of us in this house but
what can we do if everybody simply tries
to pursue their own interests it's sad
to see that unfortunately in the
European
Union there's actually a lot of
disunion
because
although we look like we're serving
Europe there's actually a desire to
serve one's own interest and serve
oneself the European Union from that
perspective is a failure because
unfortunately we haven't been able in
very sad to say to work for the common
good to overcome our personal
selfishness to try to achieve a
universalism of interest thank you one
minute and a
half thank you very much um prime
minister in this chamber we've seen many
heads of state and government but yours
is a unique case you're the only prime
minister to be stand here before us who
has left the government in the hands of
fugitive of uh justice some of the most
serious crimes that a politician can
commit and this is
unprecedented you may say
different and if when we talk about
energy energy is um buying more and more
from Putin and it's also the crisis of
of um immigration in canaries as
well unfortunately you are between
anomaly in Europe and National Disgrace
because we have people who committed
embezzlement sedition people who are
waiting to stand trial for acts of
terrorism as
well and you have come here saying that
enforcing law is bad for to ensure
peaceful coexistence
and
you and the rule of law means judicial
Independence and the and judges were
very seriously offended yesterday in the
Congress and there've been come been
condemnation of your political
agreements we think it's unfortunate
that you're going in this direction to
in institutional and Democratic decline
we're going to continue fighting for the
rule of law and institutions thank you
the floor to Javier Moreno Sanchez one
minute thank you
president prime minister first of all as
son of migrants I'd like to express the
thanks of the span who had to leave
Spain during Franco's dictatorship which
included my parents having said
that on behalf of the Spanish asish
delegation may I welcome you here
we welcome your re your re-election as
prime minister of Spain and the
wonderful job you've done leading the
Spanish presidency because Mr faor
whether you like it or not what we have
here is prime minister santh who
tomorrow will be sitting down with Olaf
Schultz the the German Chancellor to
build a different United Europe a more
social Europe a more tolerant a more
feminist and a Greener Europe the
Spanish presidency has given successful
impetus to an ambitious
Progressive agenda for the benefit of
our citizens for example on digital
platforms or fighting gender violence it
also has to face future challenges with
the
AI Act and the nature restoration act e
members stop selling your soul to the
the the devil on a high purchase to the
far right which just underpins violence
and poses a threat to democracy as you
said Mr vber come come back to the the
European
past thank you will'll move ahead with
you prime minister asked for the floor
since the beginning of the debate I will
call them out now to be prepared you you
speak from your seat we start with Andre
halitsky and then Maria
graini one
minute there you
go thank you very much Madame
President the rule of law and Dem are
pillars and this is very foundation of
the our common European Union what I am
talking about because no one party can
be above the law and no one politician
can be above the law building majority
by political corruption is a
crime majority the need of majority in
Parliament cannot justify the crimes and
criminal
cases and you cannot ignore the millions
people on the streets this is the
situation and as we had in Poland and
thank you thank you Spanish socialist
for the very first reaction when we had
demolished rule of law in Poland you
remember the last to for instance this
was the case where immediate reaction
was very important crucial the Spanish
Society is very strong and democracy
will win so we have a still a chance to
do the step back not do mistake as Law
And Justice in Poland you have a still
chance as a European you have to do
thank you Miss graini next and then Mr
[Applause]
Baga thank you Madame
President prime minister colleagues I'd
like to congratulate the Spanish
presidency we negotiated a trialogue for
the gas and nitrogen markets and
hydrogen markets I beg you pardon and
I'd like to congratulate Mr Sanchez of
what his presidency
achieved I visited Madrid a couple of
months ago I went to meet the mayor and
I'm pleased to see that more than a
million Romanians are working in Spain
and they say that their rights in Spain
are being respected i' like to thank you
on their behalf I'd also like to say
that there's nothing more important than
social cohesion that's why I'd like to
ask in
for the reasons of Freedom it'd be great
if your presidency would allow Spain the
Spanish presy would allow Bulgaria and
Romania to enter the shenen area where
you want to be able to travel freely and
treat you the same as other European
citizens that's why I would like you
really to push this forward get Romania
and Bulgaria into shenan please thank
you go ahead 1 minute
Damian prime minister this has been
quite a national debate so I want to
bring it back to the European level we
have the Yuko coming and I do want to
ask you the question that we asked the
president of the commission this morning
what are you going to do to make sure
that Orban is reigned in that we don't
give in to his black mailing when it
comes to our support for Ukraine for the
formal accession talks are you going to
take away the council presidency are you
going to push forward the article seven
procedures please let us know your plan
about that thank
you Mardi and then finally Mr uran
creso thank you president your attack on
the Italian government is is distasteful
and as was the attack on get fielders
who are democratically elected both of
them no
one should be attacked for their ideas
fighting for your people shouldn't be a
crime
um what about the cine separatist isn't
it sh that you shameful that you signed
an agreement with them just to to get
government this this political
opportunism this hypocrisy today in this
chamber you're saying we should
be
controlling properly regulating
migration we agree with you on
that but I wonder whether Petro sth him
this is the same pet sth who attacked
mattio Sven last year for defending the
same line that you're taking here today
that's enough of your hypocrisy and your
gratuitous attacks comrade santh keep
your you hands off the Italian
[Applause]
government Mr Sanchez I'm speaking to
you now as the uh head of the presidency
there's enough hypocrisy the EU and
governments are completed in the Mass
Massacre that's being carried out by
Israel against Palestine
if we continue buying and selling arms
to Israel this will not stop to stop
this ethnic cleansing we need action
which forces Israel to end the
occupation and action which means
suspending the preferential economic
agreement and have an arms embargo on
Israel and also stop the criminalization
of solid arity with Palestine in Europe
and I'd like to remind you in conclusion
Mr Sanchez we should not forget the
rights ofo gonalez the um journalist
imprison in Poland thank you um the
interventions I give the floor to vice
president sovich please five
minutes thank you very much Madame
President dear Prime Minister High
Representatives uh my dear colleagues uh
foreign min Minister for European
Affairs and of course uh honorable
members uh I know that time is flying so
if you allow me I would focus on the
topic of this debate and it's a review
of the Spanish presidency which is
taking place among extremely difficult
circumstances and I would like to thank
Mr Prime Minister your team for
remarkable cooperation and European
Spirit which help us to push many
difficult files over the Finishing Line
we've been working together on making
sure that Europe will get re industry
realized that we would deliver more on
open strategic economy and I very much
appreciate your support on the critical
raw materials act or on building the
European leadership on the grean
Technologies and artificial intelligence
we've been working very closely with
your team to make sure that we would
advance in the digital transition and
environmental adaptation and I would
like to thank in particular Teresa
Ribera who was excellent partner for
making sure that in cop we recorded
success she was working very closely
with me she was working very closely
with my colleague commissioner HRA and
theyve been remarkable Force which
Deliver Us the success we have seen this
morning I would like to thank you for
advancing the social and economic
Justice be in a field of new electricity
Market design which I believe will bring
us low energy prices across the Europe
or the significant progress we achiev in
the directive to fight uh against
violence against women and of course
we've been projecting together new sense
of partnership towards cak countries
during EU cak Summit my last two remarks
U if you allow I would focus first uh on
uh our cooperation in the field of
foresight as a commissioner responsible
for strategic foresight I want to
underscore that it was a pleasure and
great professional experience to work
with your team uh to prepare the
discussion documents for the Granada
Summit because I think that in this way
we have demonstrated how the foret
community can contribute to the
successful debate on strategic agenda of
the European leaders so from my remarks
honorable uh members of the parliament
it's clear that the European commission
enjoys excellent cooperation with the
government of Spain uh including on our
daily work in the course of the Spanish
presidency and I have to say the same
coop cooperation exist also as regards
the information that the commission
asked about the draft law which was so
intensely discussed today a constructive
meeting already took place between
commissioner reinders and Minister Banos
and while the analysis of the draft is
ongoing this dialogue helps clarify the
things and continues thank you very
much so now finally I give the floor
back uh to prime minister Sanchez prime
minister you have the
floor thank you very much
Madame President honorable members I
firmly believe that the Spanish
presidency has been successful and very
fruitful for Europe because we've
managed to make progress in an extremely
complex International context I made the
point in my initial speech we have to be
United in diversity and also in the face
of the adversity that we are undergoing
be that as it may during the course of
this debate I've heard some mistaken and
malicious statements regarding the
Democratic character of my country and
the rule of law there and I as the head
of the Spanish government I cannot
refrain from commenting this not because
it's an offense to me or the millions of
of Spanish ERS I represent but but
essenti because they are false we can
disagree on in our ideas unable members
we can have different ideologies but
facts are facts if we want to
maintain fruitful serious debates we
have to be empirical and wield the facts
when we speak and and the the facts are
extremely clearable M Spain is one of
the fullest democracies in the
world that's what it is it's at the
Leading Edge in the the four major
existing rankings of democratic
countries and the points attached to it
have actually in increased of since I've
been pris in Spain Spain is a young
democracy relative to some others it's
imperfect as we all are but according to
all the empirical studies it scores
better than some of the oldest
democracies in the world furthermore the
rule of law in Spain is
complete one of of the 25 most solid um
conditions of rule of law according to
the rule of of Law and Justice report
which is one honorable members of the
Epp we're talking about lawfare well
look look at how your
party manipulated the renewal of the the
makeup of the Constitutional Court in
Spain during the 5 years of of its
office we have to do away with this
obstacle to the cour of Justice which is
under money
democracy which is why I would repeat my
willingness to the
up to meet and ensure that we can work
on article 49 of our Constitution and
renew the makeup of our cons court and
look at a new model for the working of
autonomous
regions the the people have spoken at at
the polling stations we now have a
stable democratic government in Spain
and we're we're there to move ahead we
need to reach an understanding just as
our political families can understand
one another very often in this
house I've seen this within the European
Council too I would ask the European
People's Party to follow the example of
of other I'd ask the Spanish People's
Party to copy the example of of its
counterparts and season alliance with
the
farite the far right has doubled it its
vote of the last 10 years it's it's um
the top right M option in a third of
member
states and many of Europeans are already
living under National Regional
governments that the contain for right
that's the real threat to Europe and the
European
project the threat to democracy is is
not having a progressive coalition
government in Spain which is perfectly
aligned on European principles and
values legitimately elected by the
Spanish people nor does it flow from our
policy on negotiation and restoring
normal rule in Catalonia a policy we've
been working on since 2018 a decade ago
you may
recall there was hatred Discord
confrontation which caused Great trauma
with Echoes beyond our borders of of
images that still make us sad no one can
feel proud of that
period remember what Europe said at that
time honorable members Mr reers the
commissioner publicly said I hope that
dialogue between Madrid and Barcelona
can
presume speaker said that he thought it
was a serious
mistake to move ahead
with judicial persecution
of political leaders in Catalia now
that's what we were asked to do at the
at the the time honorable members and
that's what my government has done we'
resumed dialogue negotiation to try and
solve a problem which proved to be a
complete failure under the previous
People's Party government and the the
results are there for anyone who cares
to look at them
negotiation and the return to the normal
institutional framework have been
working the amnesty will underpin that
Noble goal because the situation in
Catalonia now honorable members is
infinitely better than it was in 2017
and we're going to continue to improve
it to Mr P Deon I would say
that we we need political negotiation
within the framework of the Constitution
the amnesty law is an important step in
the right direction it's one that
provides which it always one majority
backing in our our
Parliament it's a constitutional
government and its sole purpose is to
overcome a
conflict and ensure we have Concord
amongst our fellow citizens and I can
guarantee to you that we will continue
to promote the use of co-official
languag is recognized in our
Constitution which express the feelings
of 13 million
people in
Spain honorable
members we're not just overcoming
political
conflicts that's some a threat to
democracy the true threat to democracy
in Europe is the Headway being made by
the far right and I have to to say
traditional rightwing parties be
responsibility of this because they're
opening up the the doors of government
to these parties in Coalition
governments and embracing many of their
ideas that's the real threat
they are the threat to the European
project this reaction approach
undermines the European project Mr
Faber Banning political
parties attacking the separation of
powers suppressing critical
voices ending the European project
they're also putting the break on the
green transition and undering the the
rights of
lgtb people
um are are you aware of all
this do you really feel comfortable
being an accomplice to that
threat I welcome the fact that after 20
years in this house you've started to
show some interest in what's going on in
Spain but if you really want to
help my recommendation to you Mr
vber is that you get to know our
country and don't just swallow the
unfounded claims from your colleagues
from the Spanish people's party please
tell me Mr vber do you know who the the
Spanish people's party's allies are in
Spain do you know what Vox really
represents do you know how it thinks do
you know how it defines the European
Union let me let me quote to
you it says it's um
for as Mega
States similar to the Soviet
Union and they talk about the community
institutions oligarchies who want to
turn our societies into Multicultural
sups the leader of VO says that Spain is
a country Changed by the dis despotic
mechanisms of of
Brussels being drank Along by the auton
communities are you in favor of those
anti-european
statements because they're opposed to
the count of federal government you have
in
Germany vo has supposed that certain
political parties be banned they've
called for
preventing people
from being given a hearing in the the
media do you think that's helpful to
Spanish democracy and can I ask you what
do you know about the policies Vox has
been working on with the People's Party
in the five Regional governments and the
35 municipalities in which they're in
power do you know they've cut taxes on
on major fortunes while reducing public
expenditure do you know they're doing a
uh away with
funding to
fight domestic
violence or Renewables do you know
they're trying to band theatrical works
and changing the the the names in our
streets and putting up signs with the
names of figures from the Franco regime
would that be your plan for Germany Mr
vber do you think the the streets of of
Berlin should bear the names of the
leaders of Third
Reich Spain honorable
members Spain is a democracy it's a full
democracy we are a pro- European country
country as it's its government we have a
robust rule of law our government is
perfectly legitimate and
capable so please don't commit the
mistake made by by the the right in
Europe in the past and Europe paid a
huge price for it never again thank you
very much straight to the votes
[Applause]
now
so
colle colleagues this brings us on to
the
votes Mr vber has a point of order
please go
ahead could I please ask you to be
quiet